was sind die Aufgaben gerne
energielaufzeit verlängern wir müssen
uns mit der eigenen Braunkohle
beschäftigen und sie sauber machen das
kann man nämlich der norwegische
Ministerpräsident hat uns das angeboten
hat gesagt ihr könnt das CO2 zu mir
geben ich bring das in die in die
Tiefsee und wir müssen das eigene Erdgas
fördern nur dann kommen wir raus so
dieses Gehampel man drei Monate wieder
mal ein bisschen Kernenergie und dann
gucken wir mal weiter das ist doch keine
Lösung das heißt wir müssen da wir
können dann 200 Milliarden rechtfertigen
wenn das eine Brücke ist in eine
Energiezukunft die wir dann wieder alle
Vertrauen haben